Здавалося б, нова країна, нові часи, нові технології...
Але коли мова заходить про політичний піар,
українські політики і донині все ще вдаються
до заїжджених "совкових" методів самореклами.
Показати себе поруч з народом, з простими людьми
- один із найпопулярніших способів викликати коментарі електорату в соцмережах.
Приміром, світлини тодішнього прем’єр-міністра України
Арсенія Яценюка, який пролетів рейсом економ-класу,
просто "підірвали" лайки в мережі. Відтоді його успіх
намагалися повторити й інші політики.
А цього тижня нібито "випадково"
в рейсовому літаку сфотографували також
президента України Петра Порошенка.
Та першість із бюджетних поїздок поки що
в мера Києва Віталія Кличка, який час від часу
їздить на метро. Щоправда,
з групою фотографів і операторів.
Традиція радянських лідерів особисто на камери
перевіряти перебіг будівництва, ремонт доріг або навіть
роботу ескалатора міцно засіла в головах сучасних політиків.
Іноді в них навіть промови схожі.
- Ця дорога  має стояти не під приїзд президента.
- Цей ескалатор треба не Ляшку.
- Ця дорога має працювати людям.
- Цей ескалатор треба... Як вас звати?.. Валерію треба і тисячам людей.
Також схожі з радянськими
способи перевірки доріг.
"Через минуту он сядет в Ладу Калину и лично проедет
все 2165 км от Читы до Хабаровска".
"Відмовився від водія і сам сів за кермо :
дорогами Миколаївщини проїхав президент України.
Так на ходу протестував трасу державного значення".
Мало не в обов’язковковому порядку
політики демонструють народу свою мужність.
Нині найкращий для цього метод -
з'їздити в зону бойових дій на Сході України.
Туди вже неодноразово навідувалися
Петро Порошенко, Арсеній Яценюк, депутати від Опозиційного блоку та багато інших.
А генпрокурор Юрій Луценко за збігом обставин
відвідав Схід України саме в розпал скандалу
з розкішним весіллям свого сина.
Просто вдягнути військову форму чи бронежилет
уже замало. Для гарної картинки політики
полюбляють ще покататися на БМП чи танку.
А якщо статус дозволяє, можна добитися ще крутішого ефекту.
Наприклад, політати на відремонтованому винищувачі СУ-27.
Дарма що це нагадує стиль реклами президента Росії Володимира Путіна,
який уже давно вдається до такого військового піару.
Навідатися в гості до простого громадянина,
випити з ним чаю з цукерками, вислухати проблеми
і обов’язково щось принести в подарунок.
Чим не дієвий піар?
"Олександр Вілкул не тільки привітав дітей зі святом, а й передав родині побутову техніку,
зокрема пральну машину".
- Я прийняв рішення купити вам пральну машину.
- А чим допомогти? Я бачу, ви в будинку живете, чи квартиру краще?
- Ну, що можете...
Сходити в школу до дітей на "лінійку",
зробити селфі в натовпі молоді,
здати кров для поранених бійців на камеру -
незалежно від партій та віку українські політики
вдаються до однакових застарілих прийомів,
аби заволодіти серцями людей.
Чим ближче до виборів, тим їх більше.